Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je suis pharmacien.
Je dirige une entreprise à Amiens qui
travaille sur le médecin du 21ᵉ siècle.
Mais j'ai longtemps été connu
comme le fils du docteur.
J'ai en effet grandi dans un petit village
de Picardie, Mont d'Aurigny.
Mon père est ce médecin qu'on appelle
un médecin de famille.
Ces médecins, on les appelle
médecins de famille
parce qu’ils connaissent très bien
tous leurs patients.
Ils font quasiment partie de la famille.
On fait entièrement confiance
en leurs décisions
et leurs patients leur sont
vraiment fidèles.
D’ailleurs, on dit :
« C’est mon médecin. »
Ces médecins sont surtout disponibles,
tout le temps.
Je me rappelle à la maison
quand j’étais petit,
le téléphone sonnait à toute heure,
tous les jours, même le dimanche.
J’entendais les patients appeler et dire :
«Docteur, il faut venir.»
Aujourd’hui, la médecine
a énormément évolué.
Mais il y a une chose qui persiste :
nous voulons que le médecin
soit disponible.
Disponible très rapidement.
Regardez, aujourd’hui, on utilise
des applications comme Doctolib
pour prendre un rendez-vous,
une consultation.
On ne cherche pas forcément son médecin,
mais on cherche le médecin
le plus rapidement disponible.
Nous voulons un médecin disponible
sans attendre.
Regardez, qui parmi vous râle
lorsqu’il faut patienter
30 minutes en salle d’attente ?
Ok, on se le dit tous : nous sommes
devenus des patients impatients.
Sauf que les médecins aujourd'hui ne
peuvent plus faire face à notre demande.
Nous sommes déjà 30% à vivre
dans des déserts médicaux,
qu’on soit en ville ou à la campagne.
Et honnêtement, il y a peu de chance
que ça s’améliore.
On a tous très peur, en fait,
demain, de ne plus avoir de médecin.
Pourtant ces médecins,
qui ne sont déjà plus disponibles
pour répondre à notre demande,
nous voulons aussi
qu’ils soient infaillibles.
On veut les meilleurs soins,
on n’accepte plus les erreurs médicales,
et c'est légitime parce que la médecine
a fait des progrès incroyables.
Aujourd’hui, on peut soigner des maladies
il y a encore peu de temps incurables,
comme l’hépatite C.
On peut presque vivre normalement
lorsqu’on a le SIDA.
Sauf que pour le médecin,
la conséquence, c’est que, en 1950,
les connaissances acquises
durant leurs études
étaient valables pour les 40 ans
de leur carrière.
Alors qu’aujourd’hui,
avec tous ces progrès,
le médecin doit réapprendre
son métier tous les huit ans.
Nous avons à notre disposition
6 000 médicaments différents.
C’est immense
et ça nous permet pour chaque patient
de définir exactement
quel traitement on peut donner
pour soigner au mieux sa pathologie.
C’est magique, mais maîtriser
6 000 médicaments,
ça veut dire aussi connaître 6 000 fiches
descriptives de médicaments.
Pour ceux qui n’ont jamais vu
une fiche descriptive -
un peu comme le Vidal, mais en plus long -
dites-vous que c’est comme
votre contrat d’assurance
ou même mieux, les conditions générales
d’utilisation de Google.
Qui parmi vous a déjà lu les conditions
générales d’utilisation de Google
avant d’utiliser le moteur de recherche ?
Levez la main.
Ok. Heureusement
que vous n’êtes pas médecins
parce que les médecins doivent connaître
ces 6 000 fiches descriptives.
Prenons la notice,
par exemple, d’un médicament.
Je l’ouvre avec vous.
Bon, déjà ce n’est pas évident à déplier.
Voilà.
Ce n’est pas encore bon.
Je l’ouvre..., voilà.
Ça, c’est la version simple.
C’est la version pour les patients :
deux pages.
Les médecins, c'est bien pire.
Ce n’est pas deux pages, c’est 30 pages,
40 pages, parfois 100 pages.
6 000 médicaments, 40 pages, vous voyez ?
Hop, plié.
Bon, si quelqu’un dans cette salle sait
comment replier la notice correctement,
vous me le direz à la fin,
là, je vais juste faire une boule.
Voilà, et ce n’est pas tout,
car évidemment, la population a changé.
Aujourd’hui, on a une population
qui vieillit.
Des patients âgés sont
des patients plus fragiles,
qui ont plus de pathologies.
Et qui dit plus de pathologie
dit plus de médicaments.
Alors, ce médecin qu’on veut infaillible,
ça veut dire que, avec les médicaments,
il doit être sûr que chacun de ces
médicaments soit compatible un à un.
Autrement, on crée ce qu'on appelle
une interaction médicamenteuse.
C’est un peu comme mettre un Mentos
dans une bouteille de Coca Cola.
Vous imaginez l’explosion !
Et chaque médicament doit être compatible
avec chacune des pathologies,
pour éviter l’incompatibilité
de contre-indication.
Il faut que la posologie du médicament
soit adaptée par rapport à son âge,
à son poids, à la capacité
de ses reins et de son foie
de métaboliser
ou d’éliminer le médicament.
Et ce n’est pas tout.
Aujourd’hui on prend aussi en compte
le profil génétique du patient
pour savoir quel médicament on peut lui
donner, quel médicament ne pas lui donner.
Mettez-vous à la place du médecin
aujourd’hui, seul face à vous,
enfin, nous, les patients
impatients et exigeants
tenu de vérifier un à un que
chaque médicament est compatible.
Obligé de, quelque part, faire une
recherche constante sur les pathologies
pour être sûr d’être toujours à jour,
tenu de répondre aux demandes
de plus en plus de patients
qui veulent toujours plus de soins,
toujours de meilleure qualité.
Seul, face à ce cercle infernal,
il ne peut pas s’en sortir.
Ce problème, c’est ce sur quoi
je travaille aujourd’hui,
c’est de trouver une réponse
pour aider les médecins
à soigner toujours plus de patients,
toujours mieux,
tout en conservant
l’humanité de la relation médecin-patient.
Ma conviction, c’est que le médecin
du 21e siècle doit être assisté,
assisté par des outils numériques.
Mais pas n’importe quels
outils numériques.
Surtout pas l’informatique d’hier,
cette informatique qui a déshumanisé
la relation médecin-patient.
En tant que pharmacien,
je sais à quel point on peut être victime
ou esclave des tâches administratives.
Rappelez-vous la dernière fois
que vous êtes allé en pharmacie.
Debout derrière le comptoir avec le
pharmacien - je vais vraiment jeter ça -
le pharmacien qui est à son comptoir
et qui saisit des informations
sur son ordinateur.
Il va scanner votre ordonnance,
imprimer les factures,
cliquer une vingtaine de fois devant vous.
C’est ça aujourd’hui la relation
entre un soignant et un patient.
On ne veut plus de ça.
Ce qu’on veut aujourd’hui,
c’est un médecin vraiment disponible
pour son patient,
vraiment disponible grâce à des outils
numériques, comme la télémédecine,
un progrès formidable
qui permet de résoudre
les problèmes de déserts médicaux,
grâce à des outils qui automatisent
toute cette saisie d’informations
que le soignant fait devant vous.
Ces outils-là font gagner
du temps au médecin.
Et ce temps gagné,
c’est du temps pour les patients.
C’est du temps crucial,
parce qu’aujourd’hui encore, en 2023,
70 % des diagnostics sont posés
lors de l’interrogatoire du patient,
lors de ce dialogue.
Ce temps gagné, c’est aussi
du temps pour d’autres patients
qui attendent désespérément
d’avoir accès à un médecin.
Nous voulons tous un médecin
qui redevient disponible.
Et nous voulons évidemment
un médecin qui soigne à la pointe,
même seul.
Et là encore, dites-vous
que tous les huit ans,
le médecin doit réapprendre son métier.
Ça veut dire que chaque jour
la médecine change.
Et donc si la médecine change chaque jour,
il faut que le médecin soit
toujours à jour des dernières données
sur les pathologies, les médicaments.
L’informatique le permet
puisqu’il a accès avec Internet à toute la
connaissance tenue à jour en permanence.
Mais aucune tête humaine n’est capable
de croiser toute cette information
face à un patient.
Heureusement, grâce aux outils
numériques d’aujourd’hui,
grâce à leur puissance de calcul,
on est capable de croiser instantanément
toute cette connaissance médicale
avec les données du patient pour formuler
une recommandation personnalisée.
L’ordinateur le fait bien mieux
que le médecin.
L’ordinateur le fait bien plus vite
Seulement, personne n’a envie que
le médecin soit remplacé par l’ordinateur.
Prenons un autre exemple, l’aviation.
l’aviation a réussi
à numériser le cockpit.
Aujourd'hui, 90% est fait en automatique.
Pour autant, personne n’a envie
de remplacer le pilote par l’ordinateur.
On a envie que la décision
soit prise par un humain.
C'est pareil en médecine.
C'est ma conviction.
La médecine du 21e siècle doit prendre
le meilleur de l’humain
avec le meilleur de l’informatique
pour donner aux médecins
ces super-pouvoirs,
mais en le laissant maître de sa décision.
L’informatique d’hier éloignait le médecin
du patient et faisait perdre du temps.
Aujourd’hui, dans un contexte
de pénurie de médecins
et de médecine de plus en plus complexe,
c’est grâce au numérique,
c’est armé du numérique,
et non pas à mains nues,
que le médecin pourra redevenir le
super-héros disponible qu’il était hier.
Plus la médecine se numérise,
plus la médecine s'humanise.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)